each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's a pleasure for me to welcome Kaba
carino from politecnico the wiener
movano and by way of UCLA who will talk
to us about some combination of temporal
databases and schema evolution the
system is called panta rhei Kyle thank
you very much for introduction so i will
present you part of my PhD thesis which
is a solid about database evolution so
our motto is panta rhei which means
everything in a state of flux and this
is particularly true for the business
reality which is continuously changes
and forces they integrate the
information system underneath to
continuously adopt to evolving
requirements and this is has been
studied is a bad problem evolving
software evolving information system it
actually costs a lot can cost up to
seventy-five percent of of the overall
cost and as a database person I focus on
the problem of devolution of the data
management corporate information system
in particular I concentrate on the on
the issue of scheme evolution so how we
can try to better support the
applications when the schema need to
change and the problem of archiving the
content of the database for example to
meet the contributing obligations of a
company and and of course when you when
you evolve one thing the company
continuously do is merge and acquire
each other and so you have to integrate
information system and that the data
management level is often end up being a
poem of that integration or related that
exchanging and similar so uh do you my
PhD I had the great opportunity to visit
professors on you all for over near
knauf at UCLA and in fact my thesis is a
little bit onto side of the Atlantic
Ocean and two side of the problem in
politecnico I work and on that
integration and that extraction with an
approach based on anthologies and some
work on context-aware data filtering and
in the lab of professors and you all
work on the problem of scheme
evolution and dub is archival so today
will not have time to talk about both so
I will focus on the problem of evolution
and databases and of course I'm
available if you want to talk later in
the in the meeting we have to about the
rest it's it's I will be happy so the
problem scheme revolution it's a well
known and long-standing problem and
traditional has been very difficult to
understand xle at least 44 day for a
researcher especially for academic
researcher to exactly understand it
what's the overall impact of evolution
on a database and what characteristic
has is this type of evolution so before
starting the actual work and skin
volution we decided that it was needed
some some better understanding of the
problem so what we did is analyze
information system luckily today there
are web information system some of them
are open source in nature like Wikipedia
so we had a good good set of information
about what they were doing Wikipedia as
is a popular website and as a relational
database back-end that actually store
the entire database the entire content
of the website so was a good example
it's very popular everyone knows about
it and it's open source we can both get
to that I and release the information
that we obtain and we discover it was
actually a pretty interesting case with
a over 170 schema versions in four and a
half years of 5 time and there was also
a big need for archiving the content of
the database they actually need the
transaction time database unity even if
they probably don't say it in the same
way because about thirty percent of
their schema was actually dedicated to
time stamping the content maintaining
archived version of day of the content
or deleted version of the of the images
etc and so what the use of these this
work has been to assess the severity of
the problem itself and to in a sense
guide the design of our of our systems
in particular love the language of
schema modification operators that as I
will present this is quite central in
our in our work to give an idea of the
analysis I I post a couple of
of the statistic that we can collect
from for the Wikipedia case one was
showing the schema sites in terms of a
number of columns in each version in
subsequent version so this she goes from
about 100 to 250 so it's it's growing
quite a lot and this goes together with
the popularity of the website and all
the features that have been added little
by little and on the other side this
spikes okay that's the problem is that
even in the publicly released schemas
which are the one we were using not not
the internal development one sometime
they have cemented a synthetic mistake
in the schema so the actual script that
is supposed to load the schema will not
actually work and will only load that
some two or three table there and so its
end up having this despite like this I
left them there because they in a sense
they represent part of the program of
evolution on the other side I show
what's the impact what can be the impact
on their own application so what we show
is the query success if we take a bunch
of queries that used to run and were
designed for schema 28 and we try just
to blindly execute them in the
subsequent schema versions and as you
can see there is no much success in
doing that it means that even a little
bit few differences in the schema can
actually break a lot of queries and this
represent part of what we want to try to
solve so the Wikipedia example was very
useful for us and give us a lot of
feedback so we decided to volley be
beyond wikipedia we develop a tool suite
to automatic automate the collection of
these kind of information about the
evolution of a system and to run
analysis on top of that in an automatic
way and the process at the moment is
collecting a very large data set of
these evolution history at the moment we
are around 180 evolution histories from
scientific databases like the geneve
Stern the Nuclear Research Center in
engine heaven and several genetic data
bases of course open source information
system at some administrative databases
from the Italian government so it is
creating basically this big pool of real
examples and to use these for
benchmarking to
is that that support scheme evolution
and to have a clear idea of what skin
evolution at the moment we are planning
to survey about 30 open-source
commercial and academic tools iran to
create a good picture of what's the
problem what are the solutions and i
guess in general this kind of data can
be useful not only for benchmarking
scheme evolution but in general for
creating benchmark and having you know
feedback for example for the idea of
mapping composition the benchmark that
Phil Benson was suggesting in one of his
recent paper can probably be based on on
some real data and trying to see what
how the various tool would do mapping
Capricia tube would do to try to follow
the revolution that happen in these in
these cases and of course you're going
to release everything for public use so
let's see how we try to solve the
problem now now the day and I analyze
the problem and it looks pretty clear
what it is the punter a framework is is
the effort that we're doing the you so
late for solving the problem of
evolution so there's three main system
that collaborate tightly to to solve
this problem one is the problem the
system prism that is the first one I
will present and I will give you a short
demo of it which basically support
scheme evolution for a snapshot database
or like regular databases and use schema
mapping and query writing to support
that the second system is called prima
and basically add archival
functionalities on top of what prison is
capable of doing and there is a bunch of
optimization we have to put in place to
actually be able to make things running
fast enough and the hmm sort of
complement the other two by maintaining
the sort of a documentation of the
evolution so meta data histories and
allow temporal queries on top of the
meta data history this can be useful so
let's see sku evolution we typically
start from a database db1 here's
corresponding K minus 1 and and a bunch
of queries q one that runs just fine for
business needs but we need to store more
data we need to start data differently
to be faster for example support new
functionalities so we need to move to a
new schema has to so what typical is
happens is that the database
administrator will write down some SQL
script that changes the schema some are
SQL script that migrate the data from
version schema 12 schema 2 and the
application developer will probably need
to tweak their queries to run on the new
schema and this was typically happens
today unfortunately this is open again
and again and again so we have this kind
of process happen every time we have we
change the schema to give you an idea
wikipedia we said 170 SQL version if you
go toward the scientific databases that
ensemble genetic database they had 410
schema versions in nine years of history
so this means about a schema version
every week or every ten days that little
bit too much I mean it's a lot of really
working of the query especially cuz in
the case of Wikipedia here say the
impact of on queries up to seventy
percent of the query need to be manually
adapted after each evolution step this
is like the worst case but it means that
if I have hundreds of cases it means I'm
doing a lot of work and also this is a
problem for for the data migration
because every time we do data migration
there is a risk of like losing data
because I did something wrong in the
script they migrate the data or there is
some I might create redundancy and even
the efficiency of the migration if you
talk with people that work on
astrological databases they say that
even adding one single column might
takes weeks because they have petabytes
of data in each table so even the
migration might be costly and the
efficiency of the new design is also
stake how fast will run my queries on
the new design so what we would like to
be the scheme evolution ah we would like
to have the design process itself to be
somewhat assisted and and predictable so
have an idea of what will will be the
outcome for down and schema etc the data
migration scripts we don't want to
really want to take care of that let's
let's have some tool to generate them
and the legacy queries will be wonderful
to have them somewhat automatically
adapted to run in the new schema and the
same goes for views updates and all the
rest of the objects that we have within
a database system
when you move from database to database
it's monotonic in terms of the
information content right
ah no no none needed to be it might be
that some some work you want talks about
something that you decided not just or
any huh there's no way I mean deck in
the case you cannot support Creek you
want anymore but that would be the user
choice if I decide that for example I
have a query to ask about engineers and
I fired all the engineers my company at
that point I don't have I don't need to
support a period anymore right so this
is more or less what we try to do with
our system so a general view of the
prism system so to support scheme
evolution to devolution design we define
its language of skill modification
operators it's not a new idea we just
try to make it working in our in our
examples and by analyzing this is this
language we can foresee what will be the
impact on the schema on the data and and
on the queries to automate the data
migration we just generate SQL script
out of this language and to automate a
query support we will derive a logical
mapping so correspondences between
subsequent schema version and use this
information in to do the query writing
and the current work is basically try to
make the same work working also for the
update and so I having a better
understanding of the integrity
constraint and propagating them in and
see what happened in for the updates and
it's all a bit more tricky so the
language we have our modification
operators each operator represent an
atomic change and by combining them we
can create complex evolution steps and
the idea is that they've been designed
and tested on day on the Wikipedia
example and they cover the entire
wikipedia example and if we try to apply
them to the other cases we collected the
we have a coverage of day of the
evolution step of by ninety-nine point
nine percent which I will call it a
success by now and we will see later how
we can try to make it to that like 0.1
percent more and so that is that each
operator works both on the scheming on
the data so when I say join table 18 to
see I mean create a new table see
populating it with the joint of a two
input table and drop the two input table
so from a data migration point of view
uh
there is that interpreters is it's
fairly simple and compact and what we
will do is just just having an SQL
script that implement in the system what
what's the semantics of our sm 0 is
there is some optimization issues we try
to do some optimization at the single a
sumo level and there is more work that
can be done considering sequences so if
you add and remove things or if you do
multiple renaming you can probably try
to optimize their further and from
logical mapping so the idea now is I
need I need to do clear writing i
basically need to have some logical
representation of what the relationship
between subsequent schema versions and
at the moment when i have is the input
schema i have i have the sm 0 and
applying it i can have the output schema
and what i will do is basically taking
this this looking at each of these
decimal and try to see what's the
correspondences that i generate between
input and output schema the language we
use is disjunctive embedded dependencies
it's a fairly powerful logical mapping
developed by Alan Deutsche and Val
tannin and it is that basically this is
the minimum language we need to to cover
all our sm owes and we will see how we
we use it for for the rewriting in a
little so in this case for example i've
joined table rns into t where some
condition i will write to dd's like this
one says basically i will find in table
T what was in table are and table s and
such file condition and the second one
basically just saturated the first one
and says that in table T there is only
what was coming from table are in table
s and satisfy a condition so we create
an equivalence mapping between the
subsequent schemas so based on this
language we have we can say that we have
a mapping M the course that relate the
two schemas and we can define our query
on Sri semantics so let's say the
database d2 first of all it's basically
what the database d1 migrated by this by
this mapping plus or minus whatever
update comes into the into
new scheme okay that's the starting
point and what we want to do is now
answer the query q 1 over the database d
2 problem is that queer q 1 is on schema
version 1 and database d 2 is done the
other skewer version so we have to find
a way to to connect them we can assume
we have an inverted mapping i minus 1
that will bring the data back under sku
minus 1 so if this is true I can answer
my query answering will be execute query
q 1 on the version of D 2 which is being
migrated back this sounds just fine it's
what we want to achieve the problem is
that i will not really migrate the data
every time i have to answer period we
can think about materializing the moment
that ensemble genetic database i will
not much realize the database 410 times
and every time i updated i have to
propagate the update throughout you know
all day all day all the previous version
so this is just what we want to achieve
how we will achieve it is trying to find
an equivalent query q 1 prime that if
executed directly on top of d 2 will
produce the same result of executing the
original query q 1 on the version of the
tool that has been migrated back this is
our job finding this quick you one and
the problem is that we actually were
assuming to have an inverted mapping and
minus one the user is giving me the back
pain m which is the one forward now I
have to invert it d DS Arnott really
friendly for for when it comes to
invertibility has been studied recently
by Italian dead languages will
be too powerful to to do in version so
what we will try to do is invert in
decimals and then derive the diverted
deities and these works because the set
of Dedes we need the entire power of the
language but we don't use all the
construct of the language you know that
in all the places so the idea here is
the following when we have to invert
decimals are still a couple of issues
one is that not every assimil as a
perfect inverse as you can imagine if i
drop a table there is not much i can do
to invert it then go back to the exact
same database so what we need to do is
using the notion of quasi inverse again
introduced recently by the IBM group and
and then the notion of quasi inverse is
something like intuitively the best we
can do meaning whatever dollar we lost
our is lost but we will try to bring
back everything that survived the wave
forward we will try to bring it back
that's one last intuition and the best
that you can do might be better than the
best I can do ya know the definition is
this little bit more formal than that as
you can expect from from from this group
of people but down this path what why
not why not process the query by
treating mapping em as a local as being
laughing and then just and then just use
answering queries using abused as would
you come out with a different answer
than doing it this way one of the
opportunity that we have is actually
once we invert the mapping using that
data information to generate views and
exactly supporting supporting the
original query using vuze did is yeah
because we use the inverse do to support
it the lab to em treated as allowed
thinking about if if there is there
issues like equivalence versus the
general data integration approach which
just requires sound I think it might it
might do I haven't I haven't considered
that so the other issues was did not not
every sm 0 as a unique adverse so but
think about this we are a design time
here so we can still ask the database
administrator to help us and to
disambiguate the cases in which the
inverse is not unique so just to have a
couple of examples cosine inverse for
example you have a join table RNs into T
and let's think that this is join in
which not every topple in our and ask
participate to join so I'm losing
information by by doing this but I can
use the decomposed to go back and
whatever that I survived the joint will
be redistributed into table RNs the
actual definition of quasi in verse
means that if now I decompose the data
back if they bring the forward again I
will lose nothing more so will I will
obtain that the identity on the target
now about the multi-point versus one of
the RAS emojis a coffee table r and s
are into s and we create two copies of
the same table and now how to go back it
depends of what we do with these two
tables okay in the database
administrator will tell us what's the
use of these a done by the application
if I if I have some guarantee that they
are perfectly redundant all the time
then it's enough to drop the table s and
I will go back to exact same database if
if the Templar is sort of an old copy
and table ass is the one on which
actually new interesting data comes in
then probably the DBA want to drop the
table are and rename s into our because
you want to bring back the data or if
both receive interesting material we
want to merge them so Union them back to
the table are and this depends choosing
between these depends basically on what
will be the the semantic also of the
rewriting and so how we going to support
the old queries on top of the new
database so what we have the inverted s
knows we can derive the inverted dd's
which now specify
the relationship in the other direction
so from the d2 towards v1 and we can use
this information by means of using a
technique called chase and back chase
that will basically is going to add
atoms to the query and remove atoms to
the query guaranteeing the equivalence
and of course we will not do it randomly
but we will try to add items from the
queries expressive scheme is one now I
will try to add atoms that part that are
from scheme is to using the mapping that
i have and i will try to remove autumn
from s1 and if i succeed to get the
query completely espresso only on s2 and
still be equivalent then I succeed doing
my rewriting so the Chasen packages has
been studied by Papa tannin and Android
and in fact we use Mars as a query
writing engine is a highly optimized
implementation of the chase and back
chases developer at UCSD by Alan
Deutsche which is also quarter of some
of our of the papers of the contrary
framework and so we use Mars to do this
query writing so uh what's what are the
issue here from an implementation point
of view we have a web box interface that
support the database administrator
during the development and will be
damned when I CD and I have a preview of
this in a couple of slides and a runtime
what we can do is support the queries as
online query writing or as I was
anticipating before by creating composed
views that go from the scheme is want to
skim s2 to create this we use i will use
the same query writing engine but i will
use it at the design time i will issue
some query something like select star
from table and i will write that into an
approver into an equivalent query in the
target database and now i can just set
up a view that is the table that i have
and the body will be whatever they were
writing is and so in this way i don't
need to trust my research prototype tool
to run it at runtime to support
application generate that you
em was not invertible what what kind of
view comes out and do you give up where
you just produce the best did know the
chase on back jaisa either can make it
for an equivalent or just give up
physically this area and i know it's
different from what you you can do with
with the system that you were developing
which can much realize part of it on the
way and yeah definitely from this point
of view either you obtain an equivalent
query or you just don't cannot support
the queries terminate me if you evolve a
database short term obviously it's great
if you can take your old queries and run
them against the new database but at
some point you've got to translate the
queries when this can't go on you can't
keep running it through a rewriting
engine every time so presumably you do
need that you do need to do the inverse
and produce the view and be able to do
community is that this can be a tool
that basically support the work of also
that the application developer so that
is that you will have to do the
rewriting yourself if you don't lose a
tool like this if you use the tool that
to provide a suggestion about how we can
do the rewriting and probably what you
want to do is to check the rewriting
make sure that is optimal and works fine
for you and probably embed directly that
new query inside your application so you
can try to say that completely
transparent leave for the application
application will keep working but most
probably what will happen in a real
scenario is that people want to see what
these rewriting is and and it that just
will speed up the process of migrating
applications that's that's my view on
this period so the rewriting is
comprehensible but
very much very much and because the
DeMars rewriting engine has been born as
an optimization engine so what it also
does is removing extra unneeded atoms
and and and trying to squeeze it down so
the result a I've had in on their own
the wikipedia i will show you with it
with it with it with a tool but um they
make sense the only the only funny thing
is that i don't know for example the
alice is choosing for the table will be
0 x 1 instead of something more
meaningful for for human but if you if
you accept this this little thing it's
it's more or less reasonable from the
old i would say i would say it's just
enough to use for example the initial of
the table that make it unique some house
and if it's really unique you say table
page as p instead of as x 0 so so when
we when we finish the system we were
like okay how we can test this okay yeah
we can make sure that that actually
worked so we make a test and they're gay
again we use wikipedia and we used so
the oldest chemo wikipedia use the query
we have that access to an online
profiler that actually provided the
actual career running on the wikipedia
installations and we struck template
from that period and we basically run
those and we use the data they actually
release to make the rewriting sorry
their execution time measurement and we
have to two things that we want to make
sure one is that the system actually
cures a lot of queries and it's actually
capable of rewriting a lot of queries
and that the rewriting is actually
decent in speed in the integral result
so for first good news 97.2 percent of
yes or spikes and Lovecraft they're
correlated down
they are exactly there's anything okay
and I just interrupt them they're not to
make the graphs looking too funny but
they also everything p will of course
spike down there because there's no
schemer to to run on in and she smoothly
got a line as grace have significance
for the spice yeah yeah they are
perfectly aligned down there it's just
Photoshop on the final picture so the
idea here is the following 97.2 percent
of devolution steps are completely
automated by the system so every query
that could that can be rewritten will be
written by the system and in the two
point eight percent of the case in which
the system didn't succeed it actually
was able to deal at least with
seventy-eight percent of the queries in
the in the group of career that need to
be rewritten so it means that we're
basically taking care of most of the
work and the user will be focused on on
a small portion of of the of the actual
of what he was doing by hand before
which is okay pretty good already pretty
good and that just given idea that small
queries that the user can rewrite her
actually situation in which he's just
using domain knowledge and knows that he
is dropping a table somewhere but the
same information can be also found if we
correlate out a tooth table in
absolutely funny way so I don't think
there is any way to to go so we will not
able to be able to improve this number
four for a while at least and the other
question was how good are they the
rewritten queries pretty good news um
did the actual rewritten queries are
very close to what the user can do by
hand so their execution time measured on
one of the databases released by
Wikipedia is actually fairly fairly
close to the today to the one done by
the user and this gap in performance
actually we check okay and here that's
the average over there and the gap in
performance is especially for creative
13 and and maybe for desire peace
there's a couple of cases and the
problem that was the following the user
was actually using some information
about an integrity constraint that was
not specified can think something like a
foreign key that was not explicit it
explicitly in the Wikipedia schema and
at that point he was using that to
remove joints from from the query so if
we try to put that
integrity constraint explicit we feel it
in our variety engine the right thing
ends with the simplification and achieve
basically the same performance or almost
indistinguishable from the one obtained
by the user and there was a good news we
were quite happy and so we wrote the
demo that got accepted that I CD and I
will give you a short overview of the of
the system ok I think it looks good ok
so this interface is a little bit
between something meant for a demo CD
and and what an actual tool will look so
there are things which are definitely
academic and things that probably might
be useful so starting point is just
running some configuration parameters
like the database to connect to once the
schema we're going to work on and was a
schema where we're going to store the
result of our work and the first
interesting part is this and here
basically I see what's the schema and I
can issue a sm 0 so so modification to
that schema and see what what's going to
happen and assistant help me doing this
so let's say for example I start from
something simple something like renamed
table archive into my archive and the
system we show me that table archive
will disappear and in the skin the final
schema I will have a table my archive so
let's say I like that and for example
I'm crazy and want to drop the table
page from Wikipedia this means that the
entire week we just will stop working
but let's assume that's my goal and the
system says the syntax is fine but pay
attention because drop table is not
information preserving it's like saying
you're crazy but it's a little more
polite than that so we drop the table
page and I don't know what for example
can copy table blobs in two blobs too
and I was telling me copy table well
it's pretty obvious but it's generating
redundancy here so go ahead if you want
and I want to go ahead and then I'll
show you an example of let's say I
decompose they compose table text which
contain the text of wikipedia
into t1 and I'm put Teddy there and the
actual text and they will t2 where put
the ID and the flags which are random
other attribute so I throw it in there
and again here appears t1 and t2 now I
have to go to the next part and see what
happened to the inverses and and what
the system can do with this so what
system does is for each smoe try to come
up with out with a new verse and so for
example rename table archive into my
archive it does the opposite my archive
into archive it's fairly obvious for the
drop table page you will say well i mean
the dollar a gun we cannot do much with
that but at least we have the same look
in the schema we would create an empty
an empty page an empty table page with
the same attributes and coffee table
blobs here is suggest emerge of the two
tables of course I kind of write this
and say no drop table blobs to for
example because I know that the two will
be just redundant and decomposes come up
with a with a joint of the two in this
case is using the the common attribute
to make the join and what we are doing
now is being a little more specific with
the integrity constraint so you can also
tell you you need more evenly one you're
missing one foreign key to make sure
that the the actual joint will do the
right work to bring back the data and so
and so forth I here on the merchants
union yeah it's a pretty good choice for
the name I no no yeah married merge is
basically doing a union so here it shows
me given our query workload that I given
in input and most brilliant in the
system but what I can do I mean how how
many query can make it up to this up to
this point particularly if I click he
shows me what the rewriting of the queer
will look like so for example for the
table archive that i'm not using okay
here selector from archive he says well
the rewriting will be a cured or comment
from my archives x0 okay so just just
doing that now as you can see at the
certain point it drop at eighty percent
let's see what happened there the point
is
there are two tables the two queries
that we're running on table page as you
can imagine if the table is no more
there there's not much I can do if
instead of just creating an empty table
I know that I have another copy of the
table page that I kept there just in
case and I'm it's perfectly you know
full of all the data I need I can just
say for example rename some other table
to that or copy so that the table to do
to page and and heal the system will do
the rewriting and when I go on let's see
for example I go at the last step and I
see here my query that run on text and
now will run on t1 and t2 when we make
the joint and and and go on with a
selection now I go back to this life for
just one second and I move to there to
sort of our i call it the matted DBA
example I mean that I guess no one
really want to do that much damage to a
table but let's assume just to test our
system so I do it the composition as I
did before but then on one side I will
partition the data Horizonte we rename
the table rename one column and join it
with another random table and on this
side I do a tricky thing basically take
the attribute all flags and I split it
into two sub attributes and and then
drop the original table so to go back
what I will need to do is concatenate
the two sub attributes and on this other
side I had a naturally provenance that
is needed because later on I will merge
or make a union with another table which
will contain some some random data that
I don't want so I will use the
provenance when i go back to partition
the data in order to have here only the
Dadaab that pertain from two to that
table so let's see what happened when i
do this ok now let me go back to the
presentation because i'm not i'm not
having the screen
what's going on ok I will have to switch
to mirror otherwise I don't see what you
see ok so I go back to the same o design
I will remove all these dds and I load a
previous ok test oh I don't know why I'm
not seeing it ok and I load it so
basically this set of vessels are the
one we seen in the graph and just throw
in sequentially so now I go to the
inverse side and I see what happens here
of course I'm doing funny things so like
dropping columns and think so he's
telling me ok these these inverse I'm
creating just an empty empty column so
is highlighting it in red to tell me you
might want to do something there make it
something better than that ok so what i
will do in this case is saying that i
will create this attribute as a
concatenation of split flag one and
split flag to there were the two
attribute that represent basically that
the left and right hand side of my my
initial old flags attribute so what I'm
doing I'm recreating the column old
flags populating it with it with the
concatenation of these two and and the
functions are limited to run an honor on
a top old level on this on the same
table and you can be user-defined
function or whatever you want to put
there and let me copy here so i will be
faster and then I comment on it so what
it does here saying that I i merge the
two table and not to go back what I will
try to do is using the prominence column
to decide where the topple should go and
in this case that will use provenance
equal to all that was the value I set
for for a text to table to send the data
back there the system in the meantime at
execute all the queries throughout old
evolution step and it seems that
everything we're fine in fact we didn't
really remove any information we just
reshaped the data into the database in
men
funny different ways but just move data
so if we look down our table text now
it's got pretty nasty but it's correct i
spent about 20 minutes to read this and
and making sure so it seems good to me
so basically is concatenating the to the
tools the column that has been split
he's merging the two side of the of the
decomposition on top is using some
provenance sequel too old to filter out
the data we're just added randomly there
is making a union because we had a
partition at a certain point and it's
putting everything together with the for
example ring renamed the attributes and
it's a good cuting doing the same job so
now if i want to make sure i have once
that slide one tab that I call
validation here the idea is basically I
can run some some extra query and make
sure that everything is fine just for
academic purposes I'm showing here the
entire set of Dedes which is endless and
horrible that basically are they want
the internals of the system so do the
mapping between the old subsequent
schema version that are used by our Mars
engine and finally we can get to a
deployment phasing in which down here I
generate the SQL migration script the
basically will implement wanna see
what's the time and migrate the data
through this one is one that I was
saying it can be optimized because I
might see that there is something that
is done and then process again and so I
can make one single step there and here
I'm generating the inverted views in
particular I want to show you the view
for the text so is this one here and
basically as you can see is showing the
union between the two side and etc ok so
it's supporting the table text as a
complex view on top of whatever it was
there and this is of course a composed
view because I otherwise I would have
generated one single view and i will
have like you know a chain of views but
too long chains of views doesn't doesn't
look good in to the database we
generated campos one directly so okay
this why we sin so current the future
work in prison so one thing is extending
this the most to these to deal more
explicitly with the integrity
constraints so being able to add and
remove integrity constraining and to see
how we propagate integrity constraint
through the existing and suppose this
will give us more better guarantees on
on instead of just saying are these the
compose might not be information
preserving if I know how I do the
compose and how the integrity constraint
will be I can make sure and give better
figure to the user basically and we
model the update as as mapping between
database distances and we are modifying
the rewriting engine in order to rewrite
the depth dates as well a few issues
there but um Sims is working fine you
find the transformation which doesn't
preserve information
he was and some automated way add
something to the new schema which
preserves the information I don't think
it can be done always I mean depends
what the user want to do but some cases
for example like when I did the merge
the trick you suggested was there when I
when I added the provenance colon of
course that it's like it's being done
because I know was going to do a merge
and I need something to go back so in
the case of Wikipedia there was a
situation like that in which i added a
fake column and then I remove it because
basically later on in the schema by
comparing to existing attribute if they
were equal I could generate for example
one for the provenance column or 0 if
was not the case of Wikipedia they used
to store tab pages as current and old
and then they put them all together and
split them or it's on telly with Paige
and revisions so by doing some
comparison I could understand if a table
is the current one or not and so
sometimes it's possible and i will say
it's depending on what you want to do
with that if you want to drop a table ok
you can copy somewhere else before but
this kind of a tricky you want to extend
the target table or extend the target
schema so yes all the remaining
information so you can always do that I
mean you can just duplicate this any of
the source stuff there was nursing yeah
so the question is whether you can do it
minimally yeah
there's some kind of a diff between you
imagine that you're just taking the
union of the source scheme of the target
schema and that you want to get rid of
all the source schema stuff that's
subsumed by the target schema somehow oh
my god I got it okay and future work on
presume least it is extending the I
suppose to cover aggregate and data to
meet our transformations so in in in the
in the data we collected this seems very
rare case I think would be probably less
rare if you have a chance to obtain et
al transformation and and this kind of
other scenarios so we definitely want to
need what we want to extend this sm oh I
think this is an idiot extension and we
want to apply the the query writing
feature of prism to the problem of
determining these are provenance in the
etl scenarios for data warehouse so when
you have done wrong to use the etl to to
load the data warehouse and now we can
rewrite the query that runs on the dr.
Oz as a query that was running on the on
the original database I can have an idea
I I don't really want to do it because
of course for performance reason will
not be smart but it just to have a clue
of what you know where the data were
coming from that's future work with we
didn't talk much about it it is the
similar to what orchid is doing and the
other i think is that by having
sophisticated tools the support scheme
evolution you can think of a design
methodology for database which is less
up front and rigid and be more like the
agile methodologies for software
development something like a design as
you go which you allow people to have to
design a ski mind and to keep evolving
with you in the design because you will
have better support from from the tool
side so now i don't have anymore the
time here so tell me if I'm going long
now we start talking about their
archival part and so this was prison
that support let's say legacy queries on
top of this devil loot the evolving
snapchat database and also store the
historical metadata that of course he
knows what are the schema and without
the relationship between the schema so
if we also maintain a transaction time
archive of the of the original snapchat
database now we can think about
supporting temporal
theories on top of these of these
archived and the problem that we are
under scheme evolution so we will see
that this is quite challenging and so
motivation of transaction time databases
you will ask David but I think we all
agree that maintaining archive of
database might be very useful for a
bunch of reasons now the problem will be
how can I archive and post complex
temporal queries on top of these archive
that has a an evolving schema so the
three challenges are out to achieve
perfect archival we said that in
devolution that the user might say drop
table and of course I don't want to drop
the entire history of that table
otherwise what's the point of having an
archive if I dropped you know if I lose
this piece of information and I also
want to make be able to query this thing
without too many troubles with the skin
evolution and and there are issues for a
for a query language i'm going to use
and achieve of course regional
performance i have a big database that
keep growing complex temporal queries
temporal correlation and whatever else
so there will be a challenge um so
perfect archival the idea is maintaining
original scheme archiving so the data
will be stored under the scheme in which
they first appeared so this way we do
not corrupt the their cut we will need
to take care of the of the scheme
evolution in somewhat in an automatic
way because we don't want the user to
issue queries on every version of the
schema and to achieve performance and
have expressive query languages we will
decouple the logical and physical layer
and I will show you how and we will need
to plug in some extra temporal specific
optimization for moving temporal joints
removing optimizing temporary lacing and
so on so we said sorry so we said the
schema must be the original one in fact
if I migrate data we said we lose
information so we want to keep the data
in the original schema now the problem
is that my entire history will be broken
into a series of different schemas and I
need to support query somehow so one
idea is that well the user just specify
a temporal query is just splitting is
queer into a series of sub queries each
one of which run on a on a different
schema version I don't want to see the
biologists of the ensemble database
right 410
different queries to obtains the history
of some gene or something I I don't
think is is a decent interface so um
later appeared idea of basically letting
the user query one version in this case
is the last one and to answer we will
migrate to that I answer there again
this is this good for us as a as a as I
answering semantics but it's not what we
want to do in practice because wouldn't
mean much realizing the history in every
version and so what we will do is
actually letting the user issue the
query in one version of the schema and
migrated and sorry and rewrite the query
with similar technique but now will be
like temporal queries and and things
changed a little bit so we said
transaction tie databases one of the
issues was the query languages so we
need to have some expressive query
language we want to issue not only
snapshot queries but more more complex
queries there have been many proposals
and that tend to extend the standards
now there's making enrolled in the in
the actual a standard SQL standard some
basic support for this there are two two
competing model for transaction tie
database one is top-level time stamping
in which are basically going to add time
stamps to at the top level so every time
a couple changes some of these attribute
I will basically create a copy of that
Apple and put the new time stamp for the
life of that top o the problem is that
you create some redundancy and and when
you take the projection of one attribute
you might have duplicate of if you look
at this 02 here we have two meeting time
and if I project only for that I want to
answer my user also with it information
about the life of that value I will need
to collapse it those two the application
and join and unify the to the tree time
spent 14 the redundancy there are other
ways to remove it I know Immortal DB is
doing is doing interesting compression
techniques to avoid this duplication
still you have the problem of doing
temporal correlation which is a very
expensive task so the other approach is
actually level time stamping Didier's
but basically you you put the attribute
a the lifespan of
value2 to each attribute this has been
shot is better in in in literature the
problem here is that of course you have
less redundancy and you don't need you
need less temporal correlation because
it is basically there when I filter on
department number now I already have the
data represented only once I problem is
that that doesn't look like relation
it's not a relational table it's a funny
object so how are we go with it we use
XML to represent that so before someone
think I'm crazy I want to say that I
will show you what the advantage of XML
at the logical level i'm not going to
store the history of a big relational
database in XML and try to execute XML
cruise for real oh yeah plenty plenty so
so that is that we can represent a
stable XML like this with we have
database table row and the attributes
and now the time stamping will be
attributes of the update of the various
columns so changing the value of one
attribute in the temple on them yeah the
top 0 means just adding one new element
here with the new timestamp to represent
this new value so while you use XML oh
so because X square will be would be our
query language and as clear is actually
pretty good query language for when we
have to express temporal data did good
two things is that complex temporal
queries are reasonably simple to express
and I know professors on y'all made
several tests with a lot of students and
he says that they can understand xquery
way better than a virus SQL temporal
extension and so it definitely decided
that X square will be the way to go and
that the good thing is that you'd need
no extension there's no special
treatment for for the temporal things so
here a few example for example the
classical give me the history of the
title of some given employee it means
filtering in getting one one employee
and then getting the title and if you
think about the previous slide he's been
getting this bunch of titles here which
is exactly the history and so the other
example we can find employees the
snapshot the snap shoes will be
filtering on time start and time and
with a given moment in time and I can
say retrieve employee who work in the
Department d01 and left before a given
moment in time this will be fairly
simple I will say that the department
number will be the 0 0 1 and the time
end would be this one so it means that
the topple was there the guy was working
in that company in that department and
left before that moment in time and of
course we can think about more complex
things like give me the people who
worked in the same department of Devil
May in 1987 and now we're working
somewhere else because I it's simpler to
express like this so when I do evolution
what I will do I will rewrite this query
into an equivalent we respond over the
over the very schema versions so here's
an example um Omo Valley be fastest if
you'd like to finish so some rewriting
performance let's assume we go XML first
of all the rewriting well pretty
difficult meaning that now we are
rewriting xquery so we need to use XX
ICS which are basically the DD
equivalent for xml and if we do not do
any optimization for a hundred schema
version we will have over a hundred
seconds of rewriting time that's not
something nice if we prune SMOS and we
do some sm 0 compression we can get it
down to a little less than half a second
for for 100 a schema version which is
still a little bit too much but it's
acceptable because it's a temporal query
is not issued very often so we can
assume for now that that is fine when
we're trying to do execution big trouble
comes we try to exhume is acute in
natively okay we take a bunch of queries
a temporal queries that the run on that
and actually this green line means that
the system crashed before the monavie be
the mana dbx query engine crash before
giving me an answer so we need to plug
in some temporal optimization that for
example detects the temporal joints and
remove unneeded joints and
do minimum sorts detection so removes
sub sub goals in the in the xquery and
this actually can make it this time and
you can go enough for like 10 seconds or
in 12 seconds phone that the database is
extremely small it's not something we
could want in practice having a history
of a table which is 640 kilobyte it's
just not reasonable so we want to go for
a relational now so we still like
experience language so our query
interface would be X query and what we
will do is actually shred the XML
document into H tables H tables are
basically relational way of representing
this XML document in which you basically
split the various attributes in
different tables and the idea that now
we can rewrite X query into SQL for
those for those and this is coming from
the Archies system that was developed at
UCLA and once we have SQL the runnin on
that we can use SQL rewriting which will
be as received faster to do the version
adapt a shin on top of the various
portion of the history nice thing is
that now we take care of the evolution
at this level it means that if you want
to plug a new time version of SQL it
will be enough to have the translation
from that input query language to this
SQL on top of these kind of edge table
and then evolution will be taking care
down there so just to have a look to the
performance the rewriting time goes down
to roughly 400 roughly 50 millisecond 12
milliseconds which is definitely better
than the Alpha second we get before and
the execution performance we compared
GALEX which is another native XML how
db2 deals with xml and rh tables so our
relational shredding of the xml toppled
level time stamping and this national
database because in fact here the
example i'm showing is a current
snapshot query there are a bunch of
other graphs ended in the work in the
paper but this is example and here the
growth goes from about one megabyte to
about one gigabyte of data so it's
definitely more reasonable to then then
what we had before so
if you see here we have from from the
docks we have about four order of
magnitudes of improvement in executing
that in this way a couple with each back
to db2 we are very close to what the TLT
can do or even better for for when sites
grows and very close to this next
database which for current snaps the
query is like sort of a golden standard
better than that we can't we can go I'm
almost done and so one other issue we
were saying goes temporal correlation so
removing the duplicate with a meeting
time spent so just by moving towards
attribute level time stamping to H
tables we are reducing a lot of need for
collating okay so we are about five
times faster in inquiries that would
need coalescing in the top level time
stamping but still just because they are
pre coláiste basically you don't really
need to collect anything in the
attribute level time stamping because
that are already represented only ones
with the overall timestamp the time span
that that you need so you basically
removing the need for for part of the
temporal correlation device without our
smaller partially partially due to that
also and that's probably also what we
can see here why while we go a little
bit better than the top 11 time stamping
because it's full we have a little bit
less topple to deal with and but still
since we break the schema history in in
in due to the scheme evolution we still
need to do some quality Seng there
because because every time I i change
the schema I will need to have basically
a little bit of the application of the
of the table that were still alive in
their moment in time so we basically
define a new way to do to the coalescing
which exploit the characteristic of the
problem fighting works fine for the
partitioning is not a general quality in
technique and it went compared to SSC
which is like the best in literature in
term of coalescing algorithms developed
by previous student of Professor Sanyal
we go a couple of order of magnitude
faster than that
again because we are tackling the the
coalescing only for partitioning of the
last slide hmm is story meta data
manager once we understand how to use
xquery on top of the data it's enough to
have a sort of a version the information
schema and then we can run XML queries
temporal XML queries on top of the
schema history and secures for example
the previews the beginning that is live
in the beginning as we get it in in x
squared so concluding finally prism
support scheme evolution for snapchat
databases take care of data migration
and derive logical mapping and we write
queries and the prima support perfect
archival of database under scheme
evolution and providing to ative
temporal queries x queries are default
we can think about extending it with new
career languages and support query
answering performance by having an
architecture that split the query
interface from the logical layer and
support and provide some temporal
optimization to run faster if you are
interested there is a demo paper
screencast and whatever else at that
website there's a bunch of languages on
we're here can you comment on the
expressiveness of each of them
handling what kinds of queries the
mappings you said our part of these
embedded tendency language which I
assume are basically conjunctive queries
plus in quality and my anyway just and
and also just where do you run into
trouble I mean if you try to extend this
to Richard to rich your queries or
Richard mappings things start falling
apart okay um so the queries that we
support in the prism system are
basically union of conjunctive queries
that's the debase the baseline and I can
I think you can extend it probably with
aggregates I guess without too much
trouble but we have we have to figure it
out more precisely outer joins our
trouble for a rewriting engine because
we plan to deal with it the pro- the
Delta John is at store monotonic so what
happened is that the right again is sort
of us not not dealing with it with the
negation much at least the same problem
with the negation actually comes when we
try to do update because for example
have to say you negated the pop scene
down there and what we're trying to do
is that it was basically you can use the
chase in a sound but not complete way to
the table writing so means that you can
if you succeed you basically isolate the
negation so you take the whatever is
inside the negation whatever is outside
in case you try to rewrite and if you
can come up with a rethink we really
think we will be correct it doesn't mean
there there might be cases in which you
cannot rewrite because the because
cannot deal with the negation explicitly
so we are you're actually implementing
that right now and the idea is basically
trying to see how much not complete it
is so if it can deal with like eighty
ninety percent of the cases it's still
useful if it deals with five percent of
the cases we cannot claim to have much
so that's one one thing the xquery
language the queer we supported
basically relational queries they are
expressed in exterior because it's nicer
to talk about the temporal aspects but
that's just those are basically
just relational queries on top of Korea
in fact if you see we don't do not use
the full power of XML and xquery there's
a specific kind of XML schema that is
comfortable to be used the advantage of
doing that is not really the power of
because we want to use the full power of
Xperia is that there is no need for
extension to experience so it means that
whatever optimization that will comes in
4 for 4 dead language it can be
exploited without you know requiring
tweaking and adaptation to to this SQL
new version of SQL that we can come up
with how much ah I didn't do much test
in this this was mainly work for an the
other student so I don't know exactly
how much he implemented xpath varied in
there when you start working yeah no I
think I think it's at the moment is
fairly limited I don't know how much of
that limitation I do to the fact that
the guy was lazy and didn't implementing
the entire parts and did everything or
how much was actually you know a real
limitation technical difficulty so I
know I know the example we just were not
extremely difficult as i would say they
were fairly interesting temporal queries
from from from a temporal point of view
not extremely challenging for expert but
just filtering on top of the attributes
in different ways and it is that you can
use it again expert you can define some
comfortable function that's for example
chatted overlap so you just give to
elementary check like you know tell me
they are overlapping in time this will
make the user queries even even more
comfortable as a language pisgah couple
verses attribute the time standing
we did we do this differential
compression and and it's not clearly
that that isn't simply a low level
implementation choice when you would
want to refer to it as a couple double
or attribute level the informations the
same right just a matter how efficiently
you represent isn't that is that right I
guess the problem is that um okay you're
doing if I got right what you're doing
cuz i read the paper but i might be i
may be wrong you're finding a smart way
to compress the data but still
conceptually that's topple level time
stamping so you still have one attribute
boot would appear several times but
actually it's being compressed just for
performance reasons but the moment in
which you have to return the user if you
limit to snapshot queries probably make
no difference but the moment in which
you want to return either doing more
complex queries that need for example
temporal joint or if you want to do cute
their return to the user that the time
life of that attribute at that point
with top-level time stamping no matter
how you implement it i think you need to
do still to do to find the duplicate and
see how many times that Apple existed
and and get the time span while in the
attribute level time something that is
not needed because you only have the the
attribute is only wants appears only
once with the full time spent already
written there so if i can translate that
I think you're continuing that the
information is there but the way to
express the queries is harder
and in 1q that is new
more than that not only the way you
express the query but especially the
deployment when you compute the pier
because when when I have to compute the
temporal coalescing let's say you have
whatever language is on top and tell me
just do temporal collation do this
projection and do the temporal collision
there because I want to know how long
the guy worked in the department at that
point in one case you you have the
attribute with directly the information
there I just have to throw out the
attribute time start and time end and
it's already what I have there in the
other cases you have the attribute will
appear multiple times from storage
issues you might have squeezed the
representation of the value of the
attribute but I think you still have the
multiple the multiple timestamp in which
the query went the damn couple went
through us it operates correctly on the
other compressed representation yeah i
guess you can I guess you can go in the
direction actually what we're doing um
also for the temporal coalescing it was
basically when we split due to the
partitioning over time we basically
maintain one extra attribute that tell
us where these data was coming from in
the previous version of the schema plus
some other extra meta around there but
it is basically any I think you can do
probably something similar saying that I
don't only have the timestamp for the
odd couple but somehow a reference to
where is the timestamp for this
attribute or something like this
definitely you can get this on Friday
changing the subject there's a
so there's you know kick wearing across
time of course is complicated by schema
evolution goodnight up here but there's
an equally big problem of data evolution
that needs to be solved that's him data
evolution so the fact that you know I've
got some genetic database and they
change the gene name in 2006 or you know
in my company we hope it we used to have
winter reviews but then we opened an
office New Zealand and so now they're
called January reviews because you know
it didn't make sense and so you know
I'm not short like my question is but it
seems like they're the interesting to
think about how do you sprinkle in you
know equivalent statements about data as
well as equivalent statements about
schema so that you can you know what I
want to I want to get all the history of
the information about this G including
that this doesn't point we change the
name Freddie can't you know including
that under the previous name or
something okay I think there's this one
option for doing that visits it's linked
is not mantic sorry for that but somehow
it can can be changed to work that out
when we do the add column for example we
can add column with using some function
to populate it so what you can think of
doing is something like I add a column
and i generate the value inside that
column by some transformation function
that takes gene a and put the collagen
be and then you have of course a drop
column and diverse so in the query you
will have something like after a certain
point the queries will just ask that you
know the column whatever it is the name
of the column and from a certain point
on will ask that column and whenever
they mention it will run a function on
top of that so say my query start saying
select gene name equal gene a and and
this will be through up to a certain
point in history from there on the sub
queries will say something where gene
equal change name too janae ok something
like this that's something I think you
can you can think of doing I don't know
how much you can harm performance
because we will start like issuing
functions and function calls throughout
the execution later so that becomes
function might have an extensional
representation to
that's who actually that's the way we
deal with function through the through
the writing engine we take the function
representation we say okay let's assume
there's a table that that implement this
function we do the rewriting assuming
it's a table at the end of said okay
that was the table that we just and we
call it backed into a into a function
into a function call so definitely you
can think of doing something like that
as well and I think this data evolution
into a schema
if you were at least their temples yeah
that's a good thing that's right is
promoting it up to saying rather than
having coming yeah you say there's a new
call one that has the new names so
happens that seemed like you to pull off
when you want to do people and I'm
people at the moment we are we can sort
of support it by saying you add column
ID column ID column based on how many
times I many different value I've inside
but of course it's not the way to go and
I know there is some interesting work by
tan in a one to ten and other people
that work you see Sen nibm to basically
having uh do some technique basically to
deal with this and there is that
probably when we want to stand decimals
in that direction of data to method of
transformation we might also try to
tackle this problem you were suggesting
and try to see what to do or maybe we
can have some extra integrity constraint
that we can plug into the system that
speaks about about the value of the
instant for example whenever we say Jean
a is equal to Jean be or something like
this and then use the rewriting engine
to to the magic in the pier as well